want to start today with super
interesting video from the former
national security advisor john bolton
who went on cnn and casually admitted to
planning coups in the past now this is
fascinating not in that it's a huge
shock to any followers of american
foreign policy over the years that the
united states has been involved in uh
organizing and planning coups the
interesting part is this just sort of
casual and very nonchalant nature with
which john bolton says to jake tapper
listen i i've helped plan coups and what
donald trump did was not plan a coup and
the point that bolton was trying to make
was that trump may have had delusions
about staying in power even though he
didn't win
and he may have sort of casually said to
georgia officials or whoever find me
votes find me votes send fake slates of
electors or whatever
but that trump was not organized enough
trump was not smart enough trump was not
uh scheming enough
to really attempt a coup in any formal
sense and it's sort of a weird defense
of trump and in so doing he casually
says i've helped playing coups this when
you plan a coup it's much tougher than
what donald trump was uh was doing so
let's take a look at the first part of
the conversation a lifetime occurrence i
don't know that i agree with you to be
to be uh fair with all due respect uh
one doesn't have to be
brilliant to attempt a coup uh i
disagree with that as somebody who has
helped plan coup d'etat
not here but you know other places of
course uh it takes a lot of work and
that's not what he did it was coos are
really tough work guys just stumbling
around from one idea to another
ultimately he did unleash the rioters at
the capitol as to that there's no doubt
but not overthrow the constitution to
buy more time to throw the matter back
to the states to try and redo the issue
and if you don't believe that you're
going to overreact and i think that's a
real risk for the committee which has
done a lot of good work mostly when the
witnesses testify not when the members
are opining
it is invariably the case that when you
go too far trying to prove your case you
undermine it and i think you got to give
credit to the intelligence of the
american people to listen to the
witnesses okay so the point that bolton
is making is
what trump did was so unorganized that
it's really hard to call it a coup
attempt and bolton of course is
comparing what trump did
to the coup attempts he's been involved
in and they're much more meticulously
planned i guess bolton is saying bolton
is saying when i know how to plan coups
and it's way more organized and of
course that may be but that doesn't
change the intention of what donald
trump was trying to do now later in the
interview good for jake tapper i guess
he goes back to this issue but i do want
to mention one thing which
is that
bolton
while he sang the quiet parts out loud
obviously
tapper
was talking about attempting a coup
he said you don't have to be brilliant
to attempt a coup and bolton's saying to
successfully execute the coup
you actually do need to be
more brilliant more organized whatever
and it would have been important i think
for jake tapper to say well hold on a
second maybe you're right that for the
coup to succeed you need to be more
intelligent or organized or whatever but
i'm talking about the attempt and trump
attempted and failed maybe due to
incompetence sort of talking past each
other in that sense and tapper kind of
kind of lets him get away with it it a
little bit reminds me of this infinite
monkey theorem i don't know this is just
a silly thing well maybe it's not silly
but it's the idea that if you put a
bunch of monkeys in a room with a bunch
of typewriters or maybe word processors
or maybe personal computers or ipads or
whatever with word processing software
if you put them in there long enough and
let them tap away eventually one of them
will stumble across you know a
shakespearean play or something and they
they will write it and the idea being
okay as incompetent as donald trump
might have been
if you continue allowing incompetent
people to feel around in the dark for
ways to stay in power eventually they
might successfully do it you might get a
you know a thousand failed coup attempts
and then eventually you get a successful
one doesn't really make it any less
dangerous if those are the intentions of
someone in such a position of power jake
tapper goes back to it and so let's look
at that now and um john bolton doesn't
want to get into the specifics of the
coups that he has planned to
anathematize the rest of the republican
party and that's unacceptable i i do
want to ask a follow-up um
when we were talking about what is
capable of what you need to do to be
able to plan a coup and you you cited
your expertise having planned coups i'm
not going to get into the specifics but
uh it's so successful well i wrote about
venezuela in the in the book and uh it
it turned out not to be successful not
that we had all that much to do with it
but i saw what it took for an opposition
to try and overturn an illegally elected
president and they failed the notion
that donald trump was half as competent
as the venezuelan opposition is
laughable again this is sort of i mean
what he's saying is crazy obviously the
the fact that he's
planning clues is really hard work jake
trust me take it for me
um again
if you try to bribe someone and the
target rejects the va the bribe
you've still committed a crime assuming
it can be proven of course
uh just because you were incompetent at
doing you might plan a murder
and do it so incompetently that it
doesn't succeed it doesn't mean it isn't
attempted murder and this and this
insistence on trump's just not nearly as
competent as i was and even we weren't
able to successfully do the coup is a
crazy defense
but i think there's i feel like you're
this other stuff you're not telling me
though i think i'm sure there is i think
there's another point here that that
came out in the testimony that's not
been stressed enough uh testimony all
right okay so there's now he's going on
to other things so stunning stunning
stuff
casually admitting and saying i'm not
going to tell you about all the coups
i've planned but i'm much smarter than
trump and even i didn't succeed in many
of them incredible stuff and just the
reality of american foreign policy
there's no surprise it is
the the the real shocker is
it is this casual for the neocons like
bolton
that the us
plans and attempt and often fails at
executing coups it's just part of what
they do and it's like ah we were we're
better at trump than trump added and so
trump trump's attempt is really no big
deal incredible stuff
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night improves sleep
in many ways our sponsor chilly sleep
creates systems that cool down your bed
promoting deeper higher quality sleep it
also just feels great i use it at home
i'd recommend it to anyone and i've
recommended it to some friends who now
use it as well
chili sleeps product the uhler the cube
and the dock pro
they're all water-based temperature
controlled pads that fit onto your
existing mattress you can keep your bed
as low as 55 degrees as hot as 115
degrees i like 60 their new doc pro
sleep system has double the cooling
power of other models five times the
cooling contact whisper quiet you can
control it with your phone it's awesome
with chilly sleep there's no more
feeling hot at night no more sweating
cooling your bed down like this is
amazing you really have to try it for
yourself when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman you'll get thirty percent off of
the uhler and cube sleep systems and 10
percent off the new dock pro this offer
is only for my audience the link is down
below